where we left off in the last video the
first Saudi state the emirate of the RIA
was ended in the ottoman Wahhabi war it
was ended by the ottomans but it was by
actual Egyptian forces that retook
control of Mecca and Medina and then
laid siege to the town of diría which
was the center of the emirate of therea
the last emir who was also considered a
mom so a religious leader of the emirate
of the area was abdullah who was
beheaded by the ottoman turks now that
wasn't the end of the House of Saud as
we have alluded to there's going to be
two more Saudi States a cousin of
Abdullah's father Turkey bin Abdullah
who had gone into hiding after the
Egyptian forces had taken control of
Tyria was able to come back to power in
the 1820s and he establishes the second
southeast 8th the emirate of nejd
and as we talked about in the previous
video the Nejd refers to that central
arabian region which was really the
stronghold of the House of Saud and we
can see here that the emirate of nejd
eventually expands to much of the
Arabian Peninsula although it never took
control of Mecca and Medina which were
back under Ottoman control
now this emirate will last until the
last decade of the 19th century as we
get into 1819 1891 when a rival tribe
the Russia d'un are able to take Riyadh
at that time turkey bin Abdullah's
grandson Abdul Rahman bin faisal is now
Emir and Imam so both the head of state
and as a mom religious leader when the
Russia boon take over he and his family
go into exile with Bedouin tribes in the
south and eventually make their way to
Kuwait Abdul Rahman himself eventually
focuses more on religion but his son
Abdul Aziz will end up becoming one of
the most significant figures in all of
Saudi history in 1902 he is able to take
back Riyadh he and roughly 40 men are
able to scale the protective walls of
Riyadh by climbing bent over palm trees
they're able to take the town and then
from there they establish what ends up
becoming the third Saudi state he soon
takes back the Nejd the region and then
in World War One takes the side of Great
Britain against the Ottoman Empire after
World War one he's able to take the
hedges this western region of the
Arabian Peninsula including Mecca and
Medina and in 1932 it's officially
proclaimed a kingdom the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia which included both the
Hejaz and the Nejd and all of this was
done by King Abdulaziz and as you can
see here his reign covered half of the
20th century and over the next 70 years
every king of Saudi Arabia has been one
of his sons and the current Crown Prince
of Saudi Arabia Mohammed bin Salman is
his grandson and King Abdul Aziz and
Saudi Arabia become major actors on the
global stage when in 1938 major oil
reserves are discovered in Saudi Arabia
near the Persian Gulf and these end up
being some of the largest oil reserves
in the world so this became a strong
incentive for major world powers to
become allied with Saudi Arabia
especially the United States this right
over here is a picture of FDR the
American president meeting King
Abdulaziz in 1945 near the end of World
War two
and you could appreciate the strategic
importance of these oil reserves they're
important for growing economies and they
are also important from a military point
of view World War one and even more so
World War two are defined by mechanized
militaries that need oil in order to
operate and just to get an appreciation
of Saudi Arabia's continued strategic
importance from an energy point of view
this right over here shows the
production of petroleum and natural gas
for United States Russia and Saudi
Arabia over the last several years and
these tend to be the top three producers
of petroleum and natural gas but if you
focus on petroleum
you see that for most of this time
period Saudi Arabia was the top producer
and it's actually true of most of the
post-war era recently the United States
has passed up Saudi Arabia but even then
Saudi Arabia is incredibly strategically
important because it uses far less of
its petroleum than the United States
does so Saudi Arabia's still the world's
largest exporter of petroleum and the
reserves that Saudi Arabia has access to
are far cheaper to access and say the
reserves in the United States so they
continue to be very strategic and very
important actors on the global stage